هناك عدد اسباب تجعلنا نشعر بضيق الوقت
اهمها عدم الاستيقاظ مبكرا فاذا لم تستيقظ
في وقت مبكر من اليوم فقد تشتكي من عدم
وجود وقت كافر لانجاز كل ما تريد القيام
به ايضا عدم الحصول على قسط كافي من النوم
ليلا فالحصول على النوم يجعلك اكثر
انتاجيه في الصباح
تعدد المهام ايضا يجعلك اقل انتاجيه ويضيع
وقتك في التبديل بين المهام بدل من انجاز
مهمه واحده كما ان الاشخاص الذين يهتمون
كثيرا بالعمل بسرعه ويتصرفون بتهور ينتهي
بهم الامر الى عدم الانتاجيه عدم تتبع
الوقت وعدم التنظيم وعدم ترتيب الاولويات
من الامور الاساسيه التي تجعلك تشعر
بالضيق الوقت التشتت وعدم وجود روتين يومي
في الاشخاص الذين ليس لديهم روتين يتبعونه
كل يوم هم عنصر لها الان ومن المحتمل ان
يفوت المواعيد النهائيه والمهام التي يجب
القيام بها واذا لم تقوم بمراجعه جداوي
خططتك وعادتك فانت لاذاعه وقتك وطاقتك على
اشياء لن تعد مفيده لقضيتك السلبيه
فالاشخاص الذين يقولون ان ليس لديهم الوقت
للقيام بعمل ما لن يكون لديهم وقت فعليا
للقيام بهذه الاشياء كما ان عدم قدرتك على
قول لا للاخرين قد يؤدي الى القضاء على اي
وقت فراغ كان يمكنك الاسترخافه وينتهي بك
الامر الى الشعور بالارهاب